elle aurait pu être coupée en deux
transformée en lapin ou tout simplement
disparaître heureusement pour nous notre
journaliste hélè chapelet est bien
revenu indème de son reportage avec
l'équipe de France de magie ou oui
Aurélien l'équipe est en résidence à la
à la Maison de la magie de Blois depuis
mercredi les 15 artistes accompagné de
six coach préparent intensément leur
numéro objectif final pour eux les
championnats d'Europe de magie qui se
tiendront en Italie au printemps
prochain le public pourra avoir un
avantgoût de ces numéros dès ce weekend
mais pour vous c'est
ten objet
inanimé avez-vous donc une
arme et si c'était
vrai sur la scène de la maison de la
magie Annabelle une mentaliste qui teste
le numéro qu'elle a conçu il y a un an
dans le noir face à elle six coach
professionnels ils vont juger sa
technique ses gestes magiques ou encore
sa mise en scène Annabelle fait partie
des espoir de l'équipe de France de
magie pour devenir encore meilleur elle
a décidé d'affronter les remarques de
ses
pères est-ce bien le Louan que vous avez
choisi également vous avez des
professionnels des grandes sonons qui
viennent qui vous donnent tout les
conseils dont vous avez besoin qui vous
guident ils sont pas là pour être pour
être méchant avec vous ils sont là pour
vous avanciez pour vous pousser à aller
plus loin et vous sortir de vos zones de
confort depuis mercredi 15 magiciens
sont en résidence à Blois l'idée c'est
que tous puissent bénéficier de
l'expérience des anciens en ligne de
mire les championnats d'Europe à Turin
en mai
prochain en magie il y a un nombre
considérable d'effets qui existent dans
le répertoire et ces effets là
généralement sont repris
sont modifiés sont arrangés sont souvent
tellement modifiés que parfois même les
les profession ENF les magicien très
compétent ne les reconnaissent pas et
dans ce cas-là c'est merveilleux en fait
ce que un un public de magiciens
souhaite c'est d'être émerveillé d'être
surpris d'être
étonné le fruit de ces quelques jours de
travail sera présenté au public ce
weekend à la Maison de la magie de Blois
deux représentations sont programmées
samedi à 20h30 et dimanche à
15h